Ні, тому що перше, на що я очікую, це те,
що Порошенко програє ці вибори.
Вчора були збори нашої партії в Дніпрі,
я маю намір вмикатися на великих зборах "Руху нових сил",
партії, яку я очолюю,
яка називається моїм іменем, через тиждень.
І вони будуть готуватися до парламентських виборів.
Я вважаю, що наші країни переплетені.
Не збираюся сидіти на двох стільцях,
мені узагалі посади в жодній з країн не потрібні.
Але виклики однакові, вороги дуже схожі,
і їхня реакція на мене дуже схожа.
І ті, і ті позбавили мене громадянства,
і ніхто з них не наважився мене судити, в цьому й краса ситуації.
Я ж не біженець, я кажу: поверніть мене назад
та хоч судіть своїм несправедливим судом, але поверніть.
Вони кажуть: ні, ти вже сиди собі,
ти нам не потрібен навіть у в'язниці.
Дуже анекдотична ситуація, я не пригадую такої ситуації
щодо жодного діяча чи політика за останні принаймні сто років.
І це не тому, що я такий унікальний.
Просто вони дуже схожі.
І вони реагують однаково на свої подразники, от так.
Я не думаю, що в нього високий рейтинг,
я не вважаю, що він має навіть приблизно шанс виграти вибори,
він вибудував ту ж схему підкупу, що і в Грузії.
У них, за моїми даними, десь 400 мільйонів доларів
на мережу підкупу голосів.
У Грузії це було щодо Росії ще більше.
Але просто, на відміну від Грузії, Україна - надто велика країна,
і там у інших партій теж є гроші.
І мені здається, що це допоможе Україні швидше позбутися Порошенка,
ніж ми змогли поки що позбутися Іванішвілі.
Тому що все ж Україна - вона більш багатополярна.
І я не думаю, що автоматично зміни в українській владі
означають швидкий прогрес України.
Насправді в усіх кандидатів є свої проблеми.
Але без зміни Порошенка, без того, щоб замінити його на когось іншого,
якщо це не зовсім зі шпалерами Путіна,
але якогось іншого українського діяча,
українська держава перестане існувати.
Ну, не можу я собі уявити, що ця людина,
яка так цинічно зреклася всіх своїх обіцянок українському народові,
просто відмовилася від них, раптом знову стане президентом.
Це означає кінець української державності.
Україна просто може розпастися на багато частин.
І, звісно, Путін на це чекає.
Але не Путін це зробить, а це зробить Порошенко
сам навіть без допомоги Путіна. І тому мені здається,
що нині - це питання виживання, життя і смерті України -
змінити президента просто зараз обов'язково,
для того, щоб Україна існувала.
ому для мене зараз особливо доброго вибору,
може, й немає, ідеального вибору в Україні.
Але продовження цієї ситуації загрожує безповоротною втратою України,
і це для мене найгірший сценарій.
Не буде України - тоді вже і Грузії,
і багатьом іншим мало що світить.
Тож, не дай Боже.
Те ж Порошенко зробив проти мене.
Два роки тому вони знайшли якогось, як-то кажуть, п'яницю,
в одному з районів Києва зі звичайним українським прізвищем,
перейменували його в Міхеіла Саакашвілі
і зареєстрували партію "Блок Міхеіла Саакашвілі" на його ім'я.
І досі ця партія існує,
а мене позбавили громадянства, і зараз я офіційно
не маю права займатися своєю партією,
тобто з'явився в Україні інший Міхеіл Саакашвілі.
Ці трюки вони вже застосовували, Порошенко це вже застосовував.
У мене немає сумнівів, що це за його вказівкою зроблено,
бо щодо мене він це робив.
І більше навряд чи хтось може собі це дозволити в Україні.
Але це означає, що він боїться Юлію Тимошенко.
Тому один плюс в скарбничку Юлії Тимошенко.
Значить, якщо він її боїться, то люди повинні замислитися, мені здається.
Знаєте, я не думаю, що чи то Зеленський, чи Юля будуть зручніші для Путіна.
Для Путіна будь-який президент, який матиме довіру українців
і який буде відстоювати інтереси українців, є незручним.
Для Путіна в Україні зручний лише хаос, хаос і розпад України.
Ні, я не вважаю, що Путін взагалі щось буде віддавати.
Можливо, на особистісному рівні Порошенко дратує Путіна,
але Янукович його теж дратував.
Чисто прагматично,  якщо хтось його влаштовує в Україні, то Порошенко.
Чому? Тому що Порошенко може означати розпад України.
Що і вимагалося для Путіна довести.
Адже Путін не визнає, не перетравлює самого факту існування України.
Проблема ж у тому, що він при мені на саміті НАТО,
я просто сидів далеко від нього, це був 2009 рік,
коли він говорив, що Україна - це не країна, це територія.
Це, перепрошую, 2008-й рік.
І він не змінив своєї думки.
Навпаки, він тільки й чекає, як лисичка біля дерева,
коли Україна впаде з цього дерева до нього і просто розіб'ється.
От і вся історія.
Тому мені здається, що чисто прагматично,
його нині якраз, ну якщо не зовсім там Бойко якийсь,
Порошенко цілком його влаштовує.
Його влаштовує хаос.
Будь-який нормально функціонуючий президент для нього не варіант.
Знаєте, ця війна зараз в Україні - напівзаморожений конфлікт.
Люди й далі гинуть.
Але це наче забута війна,  практично дуже багато хто, світ про неї практично забув.
Та й, чесно кажучи, українська еліта теж не особливо цікавиться цією війною.
І в Росії вона забута.
Тому мені здається, що нині і "мінські угоди" особливо не працюють.
Якби Росія вирішила повномасштабно напасти на Україну,
то навряд чи Україна була б здатна протистояти,
тому що в України є армія старого радянського зразка
проти "суперармії" радянського зразка.
Росіяни в цьому сенсі значно більше грошей витратили,
тому в них більше потужностей.
Мені здається, що Путін лише тому не нападає повномасштабно,
поки що, і просто дотримується цієї напівзамороженої тактики,
о він сподівається, що Україна сама по собі лусне і розвалиться.
І тому Україні потрібні зміни, щоб Путін не встиг напасти,
щоб Україна швидко розвивалася.
І щоб план Путіна щодо швидкого, повного нападу
або просто очікування розпаду України,
щоб жоден з цих планів не реалізувався.
В Україні складна ситуація.
Путін від неї не відчепився і не відчепиться ніколи, поки він сидить у Кремлі.
Зараз у Путіна рейтинг падає, доводиться здогадуватися,
куди він першим полізе - забере повністю Білорусь,
нападе повномасштабно на Україну
або зробить якусь авантюру на Кавказі,
або в Середній Азії щось у нього буде.
Може, він сам для себе ще не вирішив, чого він хоче.
Тому що йому хочеться чогось такого різкого, щоб підтягти свій рейтинг,
у мене це не викликає сумнівів, я його добре знаю,
і навряд чи він з тих часів змінився, відколи я його не бачив.
І мені здається, що нині ми в дуже небезпечній ситуації,
просто всі наші країни у нього в меню,
кого він захоче першим з'їсти.
Сподіваюсь, що це застрягне в нього в горлі,
але до того часу ще треба дожити.
Знаєте зараз те, що я бачу…
Наприклад, Франція дуже активно пояснює європейцям,
чому санкції шкодять Європі. Італія узагалі їх не хоче.
Не треба далеко ходити, деякі з центрально-європейських країн вже їх не хочуть.
Тому із санкціями складно зараз.
Реально і Меркель послабилася, вона була за санкції.
І тому всі інші німецькі політики, а зараз Шредер знову
там дуже активний у Німеччині, а він не просто дружно налаштований до Путіна,
він просто і є філіал Путіна. То зараз в опозиції
Шредер знову почав грати першу скрипку.
Тобто у нас ситуація складна в Європі.
Мені здається, що Трамп значно різкіше діє в плані санкцій щодо Росії,
ніж будь-хто в Європі. Європейці хочуть знайти привід -
принаймні багато з них - щоб зняти ці санкції.
Мені здається, що Україні і всім нам більше треба розраховувати
на власні сили, на власне єднання.